[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine
football le choc de cette 14e journée
d'excellence entre maurepas et l'équipe
réserve de versailles est tenu toutes
ses promesses
mené deux fois au score les mort
patients aussi à s'accrocher pour
égaliser
le résumé du match dans cette édition
séisme sur piste la finale de la coupe
d'hiver et est organisée ce week-end au
vélotour national de saint quentin en
yvelines
cette compétition qui s'est déroulée en
cinq dates a réuni plus de 650
participants entre novembre et février
dont des dizaines de jeunes les détails
dans cette édition
équitation une compétition
internationale sera organisée au mois de
mai devant le château de versailles les
organisateurs attendent hall 50
meilleurs cavaliers mondiaux et plus de
2000 spectateurs
nous y reviendrons dans quelques
instants mais avant de développer ses
petit coup de projecteur sur les
principaux résultats du week-end dans le
département
on commence magazine part du football et
la 14e journée du championnat excellence
l'équipe réserve de versailles et leader
de la division a été tenu en échec 2
buts partout sur son teint par le
quatrième l'ice maurepas dans un match à
rebondissements qui aurait pu être primé
aux oscars le résumé du match les images
sont signés à nicolas d'enlever un match
spectaculaire le choc de cette 14e
journée d'excellence entre maurepas et
l'équipe réserve de versailles a tenu
toutes ses promesses
mené deux fois au score les verts de
mort au plan réussi à s'accrocher pour
égaliser deux fois grâce à un doublé de
leur ailier christopher maréchal
ça fait du bien en plus cette année je
me suis souvent blessé donc là c'est mon
deuxième match seulement avec l'asm en
excellence je pense continuer sur cette
lancée
pourquoi pas marquer tous les dimanches
en fin de rencontre la partie aurait pu
basculer du côté des morts passe bien
mais l arbitre a décidé de refuser la
réalisation de l'intenable maréchal
suite à une faute sur le gardien
le troisième but je n'ai pas vu parce
que je laissais lèvres avant de marquer
donc du coup je me suis un peu
déconcentré défenseur est revenu
malheureusement suite j'ai fait faute et
d'un but a sifflé le score n'évoluera
plus les deux équipes restent dos à dos
2 buts partout
on avait la volonté de gagner ce match
là pour continuer un petit peu notre
notre marche en avant mais vu la
physionomie du match je suis plus que
satisfait des deux points parce que je
pense que mon repas méritait de gagner
aujourd'hui aurait mérité de gagner
parce que ils étaient plus d'un genre
parce que y
ils ont mieux joué que nous on les a
empêchés de jouer et le 2 2 on est un
peu déçu du résultat car on méritait de
gagner
au classement ce match nul arrange les
deux équipes maurepas conserve sa
quatrième place face à son poursuivant
le pecq
de son côté l'équipe 2 de versailles
reste leader d'excellence avec deux
matches de retard
c'est important de ne pas perdre en même
si avec des matches nuls on n'avance pas
beaucoup je connais pas les autres
résultats limités je mange mange m'en
fiche de ce soir on a fait un retour à
la compétition qu'on a géré moyennement
on va dire et voilà maintenant
on va bien se préparer pour aller gagner
le prochain ce dimanche 5 mars
versailles se rendra sur le terrain de
guyancourt saint-quentin l'équipe senior
de maurepas se déplacera quant à elle
sur le terrain d'aubergenville on
continue par du handball féminin en
jouer ce week-end la 12e journée de
nationale 2 dans la poule 2
montigny-le-bretonneux a réussi à briser
sa série de deux matchs sans victoire
sur le terrain de saint-amand-les-eaux
esi monthey n'a réussi à remporter la
victoire 26 à 23 classement les
saint-quentinoises son huitième avec un
bilan de 5 victoires 1 nul et 6 défaites
on passe au ballon ovale
contre-performance pour le rugby club de
versailles et les joueurs de la cité
royale se sont inclinés contre tournant
à l'extérieur 29 à 13 une lourde défaite
de lourdes de conséquences et versailles
et sont éjectés de la première place et
se retrouve troisième derrière leur
adversaire du jour et aimante limay
prochain match dimanche prochain à
domicile contre hamelin football
américain à présent reste au chapitre
des as mauvaise nouvelle les templiers
d'elancourt ont concédé leur première
défaite de la saison sur leur terrain
contre les cayman du mans 24 à 6 à
l'occasion de la 4e journée du
championnat de 2e division
conséquence les templiers reste deuxième
du championnat ils compromettent leurs
chances de remonter en première division
en fin de saison
ils ont l'opportunité de se rattraper
samedi prochain contre les spartiates
d'amiens cyclisme sur piste la finale de
la coupe d'hiver était organisée à ce
week-end au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines
cette compétition qui s'est déroulé en
cinq dates et qui a réuni 650
participants entre novembre et février a
permis à certains jeunes cyclistes de se
révéler sur cette piste qui a vu passer
les stars de l'équipe de france les
images sont signés à patrick jacques de
dixmude jonathan roland 15 ans fait
partie des jeunes présents ce samedi 25
février pour la finale de la coupe
d'hiver au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines
le pistard licencié au vélo club de
montigny le bretonneux à participer à
l'omnium avec trois épreuves au
programme
l'élimination la course aux points et le
scratch c'est quand même vraiment bien
parce que sur piste il ya très peu de
compétition surtout dans un vélodrome
comme ça ça veut le gros mot très
moderne en plus tout neuf qui accueille
beaucoup d'évènements mondiaux et
internationaux et donc moi je trouve ça
vraiment génial qu'une convention
organisée ici
après avoir commencé le cyclisme sur
route en 2013 au vcmb jonathan s'élancer
sur la piste il ya seulement deux ans
cette compétition lui permet donc
d'acquérir de l'expérience dans cette
nouvelle discipline ses rangs une
pression qui est différente sur la route
que sur la route
donc c'est vraiment important de gérer
ça et donc surtout que là on est revenu
il ya beaucoup de spectateurs donc on a
vraiment envie de bien faire
du côté de l'organisation les sept clubs
franciliens participants espèrent
pouvoir découvrir des jeunes talents
avec cette coupe d'hiver parmi ces
jeunes il y a des gens de grande qualité
des gens qui s'expriment
la vocation de cette coupe
d'île de france c'est de permettre à des
jeunes talents de s'exprimer pour
alimenter les sélections régionales
nationales et pourquoi pas les équipes
de france ce samedi jonathan rolland a
terminé à la 12e place sur 24
participants le cycliste devrait sans
doute revenir l'année prochaine pour la
deuxième édition de la coupe d'hiver
afin d'améliorer son classement des
temps fort sportif de cette année 2010
est dans les yvelines un concours
international à des kits à sion veut
organiser à début mai à versailles et 50
meilleurs cavaliers du monde seront
présents pour ce rendez vous les
milliers de spectateurs attendus
pourront notamment voir le champion
olympique français kevin staut
originaire du chéné pascal josèphe pour
le montage
imaginez-vous plus de 2000 personnes
réunies dans cette cour des grandes
écuries du roi à versailles
ajoutez à cela les meilleurs cavaliers
mondiaux et vous obtiendrez l'un des
tournois les plus prestigieux de cette
année 2010 est en france le jumping
international 5 étoiles a été présenté
officiellement aujourd'hui dans la cité
royale en présence des organisateurs des
sportifs et de l'acteur guillaume canet
ambassadeurs de l'événement
l'idée de ramener le cheval à l'endroit
du cheval de l'époque de louis xiv et
bien sûr qu'on pourrait ici ne faire
qu'un concours prestigieux en ramenant
l'excellence déjà il ya une curiosité
d'avoir envie de voir un peu ce lieu et
ce cadre et puis et puis valeurs du
spectacle parce qu'il ya des meilleurs
cavaliers mondiaux et ça va ça va aller
vite et haut
parmi les têtes d'affiché françaises on
retrouvera notamment le champion
olympiques 2016 kevin staut originaire
du chéné mon grand père paternel habiter
ici je venais très régulièrement dans
mon enfance
ensuite une fierté pour l'équitation
française arrivée ans
fondue organisé un concours de cinq
étoiles donc du plus haut niveau ici
dans un lieu mythique dans les écuries
du roi c'est extraordinaire du 4 au 7
mai vers cei va avoir des allures de
centres équestres géant de son chevaux
seront visibles dans les rues de la
commune
on veut aussi faire partager aux
versaillais aux gens de la région
ce qu'est notre sport on a en a la
chance aujourd'hui s'appuyer sur une
équipe championne olympique et qu'on va
présenter aux gens le prix des places
sera annoncé le 7 mars le même jour que
le lancement officiel du site internet
du concours
nous allons parler de voile à présent la
8e édition du vendée globe s'est
terminée le 13 février dernier pour
notre versailles et éric bellion le
navigateur évinois parti des sables
d'olonne au mois de novembre a réalisé
son périple en 99 jours 4 heures et 56
minutes ce qui lui a permis de terminer
à une très belle neuvième place pour sa
première participation
nous lui avons posée à trois questions
la semaine dernière lors d'une
conférence à paris à regarder quand je
suis arrivé c'était je fais très
concentré un gg
j'ai du mal à me relâcher parce que ça
faisait bien une semaine durant pouvez
dés les avaries des conditions
extrêmement difficiles donc j'avais déjà
parlé à l'océan la veille de l'arrivée
en disant écoute on arrivera quand tu
veux toi qui décide
et en fait j'avais jusqu'au bout j'étais
super concentré
un donc l'émotion elle est arrivée
crescendo j'ai essayé de la limiter au
maximum les arrivées
quand les zodiac sont arrivés à ma
rencontre je n'arrivais plus à parler
tellement j'étais
[Musique]
et puis une fois la ligne passée dans le
chenal ouais ça s'est libéré et là j'ai
toujours dans cette émotion là j'ai
toujours pas redescendu en fait je ne
peux pas répondre à cette question du
meilleur souvenir parce que il y a tous
les jours j'ai vécu quelque chose
d'inoubliable
tous les jours je me suis surpassé tous
les jours il ya eu quelque chose de
grand et fort de beau j'avais plein j'ai
plein de super beaux souvenirs et je
peux je peux pas faire une hiérarchie le
l'ensemble était était dingue comme le
passage du cap horn
c'était fabuleux mais j'étais
extrêmement fatiguée parce que ça
faisait déjà quelques quelques jours que
j'avais des conditions vraiment
difficiles et je me suis pris une
tempête la veille du cap horn très
difficile où j'ai planté le bateau dans
les vagues plusieurs fois donc en fait
c'est extrêmement fatigué pour passage
du cap horn j'ai pas pu en profiter
comme vous voulez quoi
mais c'était en tout cas une libération
c'était mon objectif est le passé en
solitaire dans le vendée globe c'était
un souvenir génial
ah ça je sais pas j'ai les envies de
course il ya eu quand ce qui me ferait
très plaisir c'est la route du rhum il
faut que j'en parle encore avec toute
l'équipe et les mécènes comme si ça les
intéresse
j'adore mon bateau je lui ai promis
pendant les derniers jours de navigation
continuerait à naviguer encore un peu
ensemble
donc oui sûrement avec le même bateau un
mot de golf à présent vous le savez tous
la ryder cup 2018 la coupe du monde de
la discipline s'organiser au golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines du
25 au 30 septembre 2018 pour marquer
officiellement la réception de la
compétition la structure a reçu le
fameux potter d'argent l'équivalent de
la flamme olympique dans le monde
golfique il est en relais de 24 balles
d'argent représentant le nombre d'otages
total de joueurs pendant le tournoi des
plaques au nom des pays organisateurs
sont également aggravé on écoute le
directeur du golf national à paul
hermitage ce qui est assez
impressionnant c'est de voir le nom du
premier goal français le golf national à
côté de noms de prestigieux clubs aux
états unis et en europe
je veux dire en europe seront
principalement au royaume uni et en
espagne le seul autre fois qu'on s'était
pas joué au royaume uni mais c'est vrai
que ça nous hisse parmi les grands on va
dire on passe maintenant à notre
rubrique agenda
on ouvre cet agenda part du tennis six
élèves du lycée sonia-delaunay de
villepreux vont s'envoler le 11 mars
prochain pour le brésil lé jeune
tennisman âgés de 16 à 17 ans
participeront championnat du monde unss
les sportifs chinois déjà champion de
france est dernière de la catégorie
affronteront du 12 au 19 mars les
meilleurs jeunes scolaires du monde sur
leur parcours ils croiseront notamment
le pays hôte le brésil la belgique et la
turquie
nous avons recueilli les réactions juste
avant l'heure de temps c'est des joueurs
qui sont qui sont forts dans leur année
d'âge ils sont nés en 2000 et ils font
partie des 30 meilleurs joueurs français
de l'année 2000 on est pressé d'y aller
on est on sent bien on est soudés on
s'entend super bien donc que du bonheur
ah non on y va quand même pour essayer
de gagner parce qu'il ya deux il ya deux
ans on avait fait 5e et on avait perdu
au jeu avérage kan avait après on avait
gagné tout notre rang continuons donc là
on y va pour gagner ça n'est rien les
ivy nous allons désormais à l'habitude
pour la septième année consécutive le
département va accueillir ce week-end la
course cycliste paris nice après
maurepas en 2015 et conflans sainte
honorine en 2016 c'est la ville de bois
d'arcy qui a été retenue pour ouvrir le
bal sur cette course du soleil ce
dimanche 5 mars
cette année pas de prologue mais une
étape de 148 kilomètres dans la vallée
de chevreuse
le lendemain les cyclistes passeront
également par rochefort en yvelines une
commune de 900 habitants avant de
quitter le département au niveau de
saint-arnoult c'est la fin de ce statut
de sport merci d'avoir suivi je vous
retrouve lundi prochain pour un nouveau
magazine
d'ici là passez une excellente semaine
sportive très belle soirée sur tv fil 78
[Musique]